Selena Gomez hospitalized after an
alleged emotional breakdown there have
been ups and downs in my life a source
tells ET the 26 year old singer has
dealt with depression for a while and
her loved ones have always kept an eye
on how she's feeling the source
explained quote Selena wasn't feeling
well and went to the hospital as she
does whenever she feels off and added
after further monitoring it was decided
that Selena would seek treatment at a
mental health facility according to
multiple reports Selena has been
allegedly hospitalized twice over the
last two weeks according to the reports
the first time was when Selena was at
her Studio City home she was emotional
over an unusually low white blood cell
count following her kidney transplant
Selena was taken to the hospital and
released but days later she was
readmitted because the issue persisted
which caused severe emotional distress
we know Selena is now in a treatment
facility according to some reports she's
receiving dialectical behavior therapy
which she talked about during an
Instagram life in September I think
dialectical behavior therapy should be
in every school
I think it's powerful it's it's allowed
me to get to know myself and it's
allowed me to just be the best version
of myself and deal with this stuff you
know but I wouldn't have been able to do
it without God
if you feel anxiety and you get panic
attacks it's completely normal but you
probably want to figure out why you're
getting panic attacks last month
Selena's close pal francia raisa gave et
a health update a year after Francia
donated her kidney to Selena however
both of you guys doing great yeah we're
both living our lives we're both super
healthy it's like oh it's been a year